[Music]
as in togas Pepita our guest today is
Peter HUDs former chief human resources
manager at Volkswagen controversial
reforms to Germany's social benefit
system were named after him and we'll
discuss those reforms today Peter hearts
welcome hello trilogy de bazan minor da
montanha and welcome viewers i'm thomas
bond mister Hadj most economic experts
agree that the labor market reforms
known as agenda 2010 put germany back on
solid financial footing and created
prosperity that has made us the envy of
so many countries does that make you
feel proud must adjust ambition strides
ultimately the reform of the labor
market was a success but there are still
some areas that we need to work on
long-term unemployment for instance and
youth unemployment convicts eyes no
sweetie but are you proud until all the
results are in
it's too early to feel problems this is
it
he is getting awful tired of the term
hearts before as applied to people who
are on welfare
instead of unemployment compensation has
a social stigma those people are often
seen as lacking ability they fallen
behind does that bother you
this is the duty it is very negative
when we started the reforms we made the
name of the package too long journalists
don't like to repeat long names for
modern labor market services I was the
main advisor on the reforms and I had a
short name so it became hard sphere it
should have another name phone this ice
these are the farm I was if these
reforms had a positive effect on German
but they also created a lot of problems
the Social Democrats were hurt by them
Chancellor schröder was voted out of
office did you ever imagine that this
would be the price to pay I'm to God
justice I'm socialized phone no no and I
can't really understand that because we
did achieve result
we reduced unemployment by half and
helped put people back to work after the
rights guaranteed in Germany's Basic Law
that's the most important thing that
people can have work the political
evaluation of the reforms has given them
a reputation that they don't deserve von
espy d'emic you're a member of the
social democrat parties the Hutt's
reforms drove some people from the SPD
to the left party the SPD doesn't have a
majority in the Bundestag was that too
much of a price to pay stepwise amended
so whole goodies do you suppose the
reforms need to be properly explained
and presented and we need to promote
their successes and there have been
successes but you also have to make
changes where necessary the only
constant is change today 15 years on we
know a lot more about economics and
today we can continue the reforms we did
precisely that a couple of days ago the
guys pot time the Left Party and many
left wingers in the SPD say that the
hearts reforms amounted to a
state-supported wage cut a massive
expansion of the low wage workforce and
they impoverished millions of people was
that the price for making Germany
competitive again
probably isn't as much tied together for
that stage for this is soon as the ie
the level of welfare benefits was set
very low at 359 euros yeah we had
recommended 511 euros when that is
and so that was not a success
but if you look at the situation from an
economic standpoint companies are
influenced by the market if they want to
create new jobs they have to be
competitive we were guided by the
principle that some work is better than
no work if someone becomes employed
again he or she can move on
research has shown how difficult life
can be for people who have absolutely no
work at all many in the SPD still
complain about parts of the reforms and
say that they're a burden on the party
SPD chancellor candidate Martin Schultz
also wants to revise them booth is this
a problem for you yes but it also
represents an opportunity labor market
reform is once again a hot topic for a
long time people didn't pay much
attention to it we need to find the
right way forward with these reforms you
take the problem without using Ministers
what feed us I see you've proposed more
than 200 pages worth of such reforms
you're quite concerned about high
long-term and youth unemployment
obviously we can't discuss all of your
proposals but perhaps you can give us a
summary can this concept is the tough
difficult one that scientists with
universities but some base beliefs fight
today it's possible to analyze and
quantify talent everyone has some sort
of talent
personnel administrators have always
dreamed about being able to identify
these talents today we can use software
and big data to determine what's
suitable for every individual if you
could match that data to the right jobs
you could solve the problem of youth
unemployment 280,000 young people in
Germany don't have jobs that's a very
high number that's clean that sounds
quite simple but a lot of people would
say it's a massive task how could we
reduce unemployment to zero Jewish hours
fancy it was an unfired you have to
start by identifying the talents that
people have and what they're suitable
for and with the long term unemployed
especially you have to take their
psychological health into consideration
medical research into brain function has
shown us how unemployment can change
people experts talk about learned
insecurity you have to be aware of that
you have to give people health coaching
take them by the hand and lead them back
to employment
Jesus concept oxygen you've had that
idea for a while and I believe you've
talked to French president Emmanuel
macron about it
what was his response call for witch
doctor that's all yeah foots by yeah two
years ago and our research center we
worked out what might be possible in
France mr. McRoy was one of our economic
advisors he took note of these ideas and
shared them with President Ollanta and
I'm happy to see that some of these
proposals have appeared in mcrawlins
government agenda they all move up in so
Marco is familiar with your ideas and
support some of them what do you hope
will come with that the fear Bartok it's
a nice be good money
one example would be a joint French
German project to combat youth
unemployment it could have two parts one
with 500,000 French young people and one
with 250,000 young Germans they could be
brought into the workforce together
these are young people who have no
training or they've been out of work for
a while or they have no internship or a
job but they do have training your
original reforms were supposed to do
that why didn't they work but the
universe was the same there wasn't
enough focus on long-term and youth
unemployment and we didn't have the same
sort of tools that we have today for
example with big data we can determine
employment possibilities in the service
sector on a street by street basis see
how dividing flattened you achieve
success through continuing education a
rather unconventional option how did
that help you when my mother would see
her sons and grandsons the first thing
she always asked was where are you
working right now I inherited a
fundamental belief that you have to have
a job so that you can hurt a living and
develop yourself as a person these
mythical jesus Dinkin keep my dignity is
that something you have in common with
Gerhard schröder
he was the sort of politician who
sometimes defied the majority rolled up
his sleeves and got things moving dear I
thought the font hosting things and we
do have the same background and we
wanted to show that people can get ahead
in life by working hard and working well
we both have experience in the
metalworking industry and in the social
democratic party so we had the right
attitude
idealistic dessert chocolate and still
don't become hard you later hearts
you're 75 years old you certainly don't
look it and you're still working to
reduce youth and long-term unemployment
what keeps you going then if you have
the opportunity to solve a problem like
this you have to try if you have a burst
pipe at home you get it fixed right away
if someone in your family has a stroke
you take immediate action in Europe
right now more than four million young
people don't have jobs you need three
things to change this you need political
power resources and ideas we've
delivered the ideas the resources are
there and in terms of political power
European Commission President
jean-claude Juncker and the 28 EU heads
of state need to do their part
Europe is a really great project a
project for peace and freedom it's
wonderful but youth unemployment should
be top of the agenda people should be
asking themselves how many jobs have we
created for young people that's the
pressing issue right now so the big
politicians have to get on with it
that's Europe and now we'd like you to
complete three sentences for us first
the most important reform that I helped
to develop is Angus tours and Hobbit is
medieval Easter
yeah youth unemployment performing the
reforms for cutting youth unemployment
my biggest regret in life is I didn't
monitor some things closely enough and
sometimes trusted people too much don't
stunts unemployment will continue to
decline in Germany because yeah we have
the know-how and we have the resources
this wasn't that big the Hutt's thank
you my pleasure